I love you Lizzie you know that right
let's sit amazing this is my new
favorite bench
isn't that right Lizzie that's that's
great Lizzie oh god what was that Lizzie
hold me I can't [ __ ] hear you Lizzie
talk normally please where's all my [ __ ]
now Lizzie Lizzie you turn into us would
the LASIK
listen you trying to trick me Oh what's
up here sorry I was just oh god I gotta
go what I see some people over there
what do they want
let's stay away for now Oh God I think
they see me bird you tweeted didn't you
you bet I think they have something out
for your arm I think they don't like you
or was it hand yeah I was hand you
really do come in handy
why aren't you laughing
[Music]